this is why Twitter has 13 billion
dollars in new debt that it took on at
the end of 2022.
Elon Musk didn't start Twitter's
problems it hadn't booked an annual
profit since 2019 but in the months
after that tweet its finances have
drained Revenue fell an estimated 40
percent year-over-year in December still
musk is projecting optimism I think
we've got a shot at being cash flow
positive uh next quarter but just how
possible is that let's look at Twitter's
cash flow before and after musk's
takeover to see how its Revenue has
changed and why he insists Twitter will
take flight again soon
[Music]
er's cash flow problems started before
musk's takeover of the company it had
posted a loss in eight of the last 10
years the last full year that we have
figures for is 2021 they booked about 5
billion in Revenue
and also booked about 5.5 billion in
costs which goes to show that the
company's finances even before the
Takeover were a little stressed but for
the money it was making it relied
heavily on Advertising take a look at
the second quarter of 2022 advertising
accounted for more than 90 percent of
Twitter's Revenue
fast forward to October when Elon Musk
purchased Twitter for 44 billion dollars
that buy saddled the company with that
13 billion dollars in debt analysts
estimated at the time that this would
put Twitter on the hook for annual
interest payments of more than one
billion dollars compared to 51 million
in 2021. the debt is going to drain the
company's resources he added a huge
burden to the company's finances
came in with big ideas for Twitter
including cutting down its Reliance on
Advertising revenue and focusing on
subscription services
but one idea that he focused heavily on
was promoting what he refers to as free
speech
musk began reinstating accounts that had
been banned for tweets that violated
policies and limiting content moderation
Twitter has become a little bit more of
a chaotic platform and place since Elon
took over last year saw a Slowdown in
online marketing that affected many
platforms due to people spending less
time online and broader economic
concerns but Twitter had additional
issues because some of musk's changes
didn't sit well with some big
advertisers
within weeks of the Takeover companies
including Chipotle and United Airlines
had pulled back or paused their ad
spending on the platform hurting
Twitter's primary source of Revenue
advertisers are really focused on brand
safety so that when their ads appear
online or anywhere for that matter they
want to know that the content that it's
surrounding is not offensive or not
inflammatory
musk has said Twitter must be a
respectable platform for advertisers and
Twitter says brand safety is a priority
while advertisers fled musk was taking
stock of his new company he said in
early November the Twitter was losing 4
million dollars a day because I'm just
thinking about like how do we
um
you know uh just get Twitter to be in a
financially healthy place the main way
that's being addressed we're told is
through cost cutting Twitter went from
about 8 000 employees before the sale to
around 2 000 in December but these job
Cuts have come with their own price when
used fire whole teams and take them off
the site suddenly there are people who
had expertise in running a very
complicated machine that are not around
anymore
and it's not a surprise that there have
been unexpected unplanned outages
Twitter hasn't said much about recent
outages but the company responded to a
request for comment with this
aside from cost cutting Twitter has made
moves to grow Revenue please subscribe
to Twitter verified eight bucks
and uh actually it's technically at 7.99
so uh slightly less in December it
relaunched its paid Subscription Service
Twitter blue
as of March it's estimated that the
subscription service has about 450 000
users according to Travis Brown a
software developer who tracks social
media platforms now Twitter blue is 11
for mobile phone users we haven't seen a
big uptake of Twitter blue yet there
aren't enough incentives yet or reasons
to join Twitter blue to cause a mass
sign up so musk is also appealing to
advertisers to come back to the platform
what I'd say to advertisers and Brands
is you know use Twitter yourself and
believe what you see on Twitter not what
you read in the newspapers
because what you see on Twitter is the
real thing and what you read newspapers
is not currently musk says the company
earns five to six cents an hour spent by
its users on the platform an amount musk
isn't satisfied with
still he sees potential saying there
will be a massive increase in the
revenue because it is now useful he
sincerely believes that through targeted
advertising more specific forms of
content instead of just general ads for
the public writ large advertisers will
spend more because they feel like
they're reaching their target audience
on Twitter but are these efforts enough
to actually make that happen
one analyst says the company could at
least break even in nine months based on
estimates of recent Cost Cuts and
stabilizing ad Revenue
Twitter could also negotiate down its
interest payments and musk could
contribute more of his personal wealth
but whether the company books a profit
depends on what direction musk takes
he wants to turn it into like an
everything platform where you can
essentially integrate commercial
activity with reading the news with
talking to friends and I think that's
the long-term Vision but first he's got
to be sure that the company can pay its
bills and that is still a bit in
question